Oh
shut it down
a big reason I came here is for the
music on the musician and seeing what
music actually did today to make people
dance in the streets and say can I curse
[ __ ] sensor [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] police and
everyone was trying to hold you down
there that's not America you know you
and me are America this guy's America
America he loves it
I'm against war period up against the
taxpayers paying for the war against our
foreign policy is a whole I'm against
the media and the suppression of the
information that would give the people
knowledge as to why we should be against
the war in the first place I think
Americans have their head in the ground
and until until and people are just more
focused on American Idol and dancing
with the stars and they are about
exactly what's going on in the world so
anything we can do to get the message
out there well I hate the government and
I think that we should go back to living
in teepees the reason we're happens is
because people make big money off of war
and if we could stop the money then we
could stop the wars
judging from the time that is taken you
get our [ __ ] together
you know it's like it isn't ss-sure
because we don't want we don't have
faith in the federal government yeah but
yet I believe in social health care so
maybe I'm not well informed enough to
really even answer that just yet that is
that is like a paradox to me it's like I
mean your universal health care has
always been my major issue but right now
if we just somebody who can clean up
this mess and and who's gonna withdrew
the withdraw the troops it's kind of sad
like when you gotta pay like five
hundred dollars or didn't check up see
what you're only here loans and stuff
one of the sad irony of conservatism you
know as people understand it as
conservatives are supposed to be against
government I consider myself a
fundamental conservative right I believe
that government is best that governs
least because I don't really trust any
government I don't really trust anybody
making decisions for me however it is
sometimes useful to you know to have
streets and plumbing and electricity and
end a legal system right these things
are useful health care god yeah what a
beautiful dream right my last name is
marks with an X absolutely but I don't
know for sure if there's any any blood
connection